this meeting is being recorded good
morning everyone if you just arrived and
you didn't hear my notice from before
uh we're gonna be having a look at this
question which falls under
resisted motion uh but projectile motion
which we
started on tuesday please take a
screenshot of this question if you have
not already
and have it there on the side because
we'll be um yeah scrolling past it
fairly quickly
now i want you to recall uh on tuesday's
lesson we had a look at projectile
motion
with resistance and one of the cool
things we experienced about it was
number one it lets you solve cool
problems we're just having a look at
that um
video of the curiosity rover and the
physical problems the challenges they
had to solve
to enable that that rover to land and i
hope many of you
went and watched the video the full
thing afterwards ironically it's called
seven minutes of terror but i think the
minute the video is actually like five
minutes anyway that's fine
uh one of the things you might recall is
that we were having a look at
um situations where the aerodynamic
drag would be directly proportional
to the velocity so you would have some
situation whereby
x double dot equals minus k x dot
something like that right and so we
could expand from that
when you have a look at it vertically
you also have to take into account
gravity and so on and so on
um one of the things we said though was
that you might not have it
proportional to velocity you might be
proportional to the square of the
velocity and you can see
that's one of the things that's being
highlighted in this particular question
we're going to have a look at
today so um i want you to read this
along with me and we're going to
highlight
starting with that idea of quadratic
drag that's what this is called
and we're going to highlight the things
that are different about this question
even though it's really the same concept
that will help you learn a few different
things
within projectile motion so let's get
started
a golf ball is designed to weigh 46
grams okay we're going to go through and
as we often do
let's highlight the pieces of
information that are going to be vital
for us to write down
and take into account 46 gram golf ball
it's designed to experience a drag force
that is proportional
to the square of the velocity and i hope
some of you had a look at some of the
extra examples
that were provided online if you don't
if you've had like plenty to focus on
especially with remote learning i hope
you get to look at them later
but i particularly want you to note the
drag force
so not the acceleration the force is
proportional to the square of the
velocity and there's no
mention of mass that's important we'll
come back to it a little bit later on
its terminal velocity under the force of
gravity is found to be
44 meters per second so when you hear
that
that sentence there um you can just
imagine an object dropping from rest
and you know it's going to be pulled on
the force of by the force of gravity
but it's going to be resisted by you
know air resistance for example in this
situation
and eventually those things are going to
balance and there will be no more
acceleration experienced by the golf
ball so
it doesn't get any faster it reaches a
terminal velocity or at least it
approaches that
okay all right so now we have two
questions it says
calculate the drag coefficient k for the
golf ball and they've given us a
gravity constant uh value and then
secondly and it's important i just want
to highlight this before we move forward
just so you can see the
the difference in the character of this
question compared to what we had to look
at on tuesday
then we say okay golfer strikes the ball
so that's initial speed is 60 meters per
second all right let's just
note that first initial speed is 60
meters per second
we've already noticed the difference
with this quadratic
drag model which is that it's not
proportional
drag is not proportional to velocity
it's proportional to the square of
velocity
so there's a point of difference here's
another point of difference that
question we were having a look at before
if you recall we saw that um i think we
provided you a vector
an initial um vector of projection so it
was like
15 i plus 30 j something like that
so you knew exactly the direction that
this thing was going and not just the
magnitude of that force
but in this case you're only given an
initial speed so you're going to need to
do a bit of resolution of forces here to
work out what's horizontal
what's vertical so again we'll come back
to that when we do part b
if it is airborne for 4.53 seconds
that's going to be important
and lands 155 meters away
calculate its angle of projection okay
we haven't even started this question
yet but i just want you to notice
this question is kind of like the
question we looked at on tuesday but
completely backwards
right we knew the angle of projection
and what we had to find was things like
where do we land um how long are we in
the air these were the questions like
after we go up how long does it take us
to come back down
we're now asking um given the opposite
amount of information
we're being asked to calculate these
different kinds of things which used to
be our starting point
before so same kind of situation we're
going to use the same
knowledge but you can see all of these
differences here
all right i hope we've noticed uh all of
these differences so now let's actually
get sucked into the question
part a we're trying to calculate the
drag coefficient
k for the golf ball and they give us
this helpful clue
that we're going to need to use gravity
to do this right so
have a think about this i want you to go
back and maybe you've got your notes
there and you can refer to them
how do we work out something like
terminal velocity
terminal velocity is really to do with
just vertical motion right
so as you read the beginning of this
we're just going to think about a
vertical journey first
and terminal velocity occurs on
a downward journey not an upward journey
right um the
terminal velocity like the velocity you
terminate upwardly is zero because
eventually gravity
stops you right we're talking about the
downward journey here
so we need to think about well at what
point does terminal velocity occur
in a vertical situation and the way that
i would um denote this
sort of flagged it before is that if we
have there's going to be some
vertical velocity and i'm going to call
it a vertical velocity with a
t for terminal it occurs
as i mentioned before when our two
forces balance out vertically speaking
so there's the gravity force pulling you
down and then there is the drag force
pushing up against you so
i guess we could denote that with say
the force of gravity
at some point that will equal or we're
going to approach
equalling another force and that's the
force um
owing to this quadratic drag thing right
so i'm going to call that
d for drag so when these two things are
equal
or when you add them up and you get a
resultant a net force of zero
that's when we should be reaching uh
terminal velocity or at least
approaching it right
okay so from here all i need to do is
think about well um
what what does this expression actually
look like and then let me punch in the
appropriate numbers
so when we think about the force of
gravity maybe you can just type in the
chat
what's that going to be equal like how
do we calculate the um the force
the weight force or into gravity i'll
give you a clue it's just two letters
and i'm starting you off nice and
easy so you can post something simple in
the chat go ahead and type it it
shouldn't take you long
yay hooray okay thank you very much
we've got a couple of early entries in
there
though someone's direct message because
they're not sure and that's okay with me
it's just going to be the mass of the
object which is why they told us how
heavy the golf ball is
multiplied by whatever um you know
gravity constant we're determining to
use 9.8 in this case
10 in other questions so there's the
force or into gravity
and then let's think about the drag
force right
now they tell us that it's going to be
if you go back to the question
proportional to the square of the
velocity
so when you hear proportional you know
there's going to be some constant that
we're being multiplied by some constant
coefficient
and then when you say well normally i'd
have say like y dot here
but this is not the velocity it's the
square of the velocity
so therefore i'm going to have and just
be careful with your notation here right
y dot squared okay
and you can see here i'm not worrying
too much about what's positive and
what's negative because i'm just
thinking about magnitude right
and knowing that mass is positive
gravity is positive
this constant coefficient is going to be
positive and i if i think about this as
a downward journey
i can just consider y dot as a positive
it's going to get squared anyway in this
case
so this is what i'm after okay now
think with me for a moment what we
trying to find
and what do we know well the unknown is
the drag coefficient k that's what part
a says
everything else is known we know the
mass we know what gravity is
um and this y dot here right i can say
that actually it shouldn't just be y dot
squared it should be
uh y dot oopsie daisy y dot t it's the
terminal velocity
that's going to get squared and that's
when everything will balance out so
that i know the question told me it was
44 meters
per second so i'm going to give you a
brief moment and i'm going to let you
calculate this
but i'm just going to warn you there's a
teeny tiny little trap if you read the
question carefully
that is is sort of tucked in there i'm
going to give you a clue when you go
ahead and calculate this and please
you're going to need your calculator a
lot for this question
so just a warning ahead of time um can
you please give me
does it sound ridiculous but trust me
can you please give me six decimal
places
i'm going to give you a couple minutes
to get ahead of me
i'll give you a clue i'm going to be
making kay the subject and then you're
gonna have to put in all the rest of
those things
if you've got an answer if you're not
sure you can direct message me but if
you're willing to just put it out there
go ahead and chuck it
in the chat to everyone can you go ahead
and work out k for me
use your calculator to help you i've got
a question
uh here which is what about fractional
form um
interestingly actually i'm not sure if
actually i'm fairly certain
that is not the fractional form that i
got uh i don't think
um but uh you could i suppose provide
the fractional form
um i'm going to go for the uh um
what's the word i'm looking for i'm
going to go for the decimal because it's
going to end up being
easier here we're going to have a lot of
fractions flying around if we do go with
fractions so
go ahead and do a decimal uh and yes of
course i mean in terms of the further
working this is part a
um someone you know jazz asks should we
you know can we just keep it exact
i'm i'd encourage you to actually keep
it exact in your calculator like store
that value and then
um substitute it in within your
calculator every time you use it
but um we're going to be actually having
to write a lot of this so i'm going to
suggest you
don't get a decimal so at least you get
a sense of the
the magnitude of this thing and yes as
mrs lee's points out to the question of
you know what is the mass the mass is
given to you as 46
grams but i want you to think about what
the rest of the units assuming right
like we're talking in newtons right
newton's is a sneaky unit because it
actually includes units
within it right um it's it's comparing
two different things so i want you to
think about what's appropriate here
let me just fill in a little bit you can
see here to make k the subject i'm just
going to divide both sides through
by a bit of a mouthful y dot t
squared that's the terminal vertical
velocity there isn't really a terminal
horizontal velocity
and my mass here this was the little
curveball is in grams right so we're so
used to just putting in kilograms
and just uh putting in whole numbers etc
but if it's
46 grams it's going to be all of 0.046
kilograms if you divide by that 1000. so
that's what i'm putting in for mass my
gravity of course is provided as 9.8
and then my terminal velocity is going
to be 44 but of course i
square that okay so yes
that's why that's why we had different
units there so what i was getting was
and i asked for six decimal places
because you want to get some actual
significant figures there
i got 0.000233
i actually got let's see here 232851
etc so it continues on from there
so that's what i've got for my drag
coefficient so i'm done
okay